من ابرز الحضارات الحقيقه التي سميت بتعود
العصور الحجريه مثل حضاره العبيد اللي هي
طبعا اخذت اسمها من موقع حجري من موقع
اثري موجود في جنوب العراق لانه اول من
نشر او او اول ما نشرت عن هذا العصر
بينما بقيه المناطق في الجزء في خصوصي شرق
الجزيره العربيه ايضا هي نفس التقنيه
ولذلك تعود الى هذه الفتره العبيد وعندنا
مثلا على سبيل المثال همم حضاره ما اسميه
حضاره او نسميه تجاوزنا الحقيقه الحضاره
اللي هو حضاره المقر اللي في وادي جنب
وادي الدواسر وعند همم
يعني اظن شمال شرق همم بيشه في منطقه بيشه
بينطقتين بين وادي الدواسر وبين بيشه هذا
يضم الحقيقه همم
دليلا قاطعا على الانسان ذلك العصر
الحقيقه تعامل مع الخيل في القرن في
السابع قبل الميلاد في خلا كان التاسعه
والسابع بس يبدو انه الباحثين استقروا على
على همم
اقرب الى حد ما والقرب نسبه طبعا يعني
مثلا نقول 5000 قبل الميلاد 3,000 قبل
الميلاد
بعدين جاءت العصور الحجريه العصور
التاريخيه من اجل في العصور التاريخيه
تعددت الممالك وتعددت المراكز المراكز
الحضاريه في الجزيره العربيه اذا اخذناها
من جنوبها انا جد الممالك موجوده في جنوب
الجزيره العربيه بدءا من سبا وانتهاء بحضر
موت في همم في شرق ال في شرق الجزيره
العربيه مرورا بقتبان وغيره شو اسمها
الجزء العربي ايضا تتعدد الممالك الموجود
في مدونه الجندل في ديدان في الاحيان في
همم تيمه وفي غيرها من من المناطق الاخرى
الموجوده في المملكه في شمال الجزيره في
وسط الجزيره نجد مملكه كنده على سبيل
المثال اذا اذا تغادينا عن تصموا جديد او
غيرها ثم نجد ساج في جنوب في شرق الجزيره
العربيه همم لها دورها الكبير ايضا تاج
والجرهه وكل هذه المناطق وفيلك بجسمها همم
فيلك في في الكويت على سبيل المثال وغيرها
من المناطق الموجوده في الجزيره العربيه
واهمها في الحقيقه في شرق الجزيره العربي
وفي شمال غرب المملكه طيب حضاره البتراء
همم الانباط
والحيانيين هذه تعتبر متاخره يعني انت
تعتبر متاخره هذه
تعود الى يعني ما بين القرن الثاني قبل
الميلاد الثالث الثاني قبل الميلاد الى
الاول همم بعد الميلاد بعد الميلاد
موجود لدينا ان كان عنده احتكاك
بالاشوريين كان عندهم احتكاك بغيرهم
بنفس الاسم
الحضاره لاحقا يعني
اتجهوا للمدنيه لانه الحضاره لها نوعين في
حضاره ماديه وفي حضاره لا ماديه احنا
عندنا حقيقي افترض فينا الا يعني نقلل من
الحضره لا الماديه لان الحضاره اللام
الماديه عباره عن الاخلاق عن اللغه عن
الاديان عن الديانات الاساطير غيرها وادي
موجوده في هذه القبائل